bienvenidos nos quedamos con este
problema y vamos a continuar trabajando
con él vamos a repasar los cálculos ya
que al final no se presionamos un poco y
después continuaremos calculando el
ángulo de esta velocidad debe y su
magnitud y veremos un poco más sobre
trigonometría dijimos que el momentum se
conserva y cuando trabajamos en dos
sumas dimensiones el momentum se
conserva en cada una de estas
dimensiones calculamos cuál es el
momento inicial de todo el sistema
y dijimos que el momento inicial venía
sobre todo de la bola a porque la bola
no se estaba moviendo su velocidad era
cero por lo tanto su momentum será cero
la bola
es la que se está moviendo en la
dirección xy no se está moviendo en la
dirección y por lo que el momentum en
inicial es ser su momento en x fue de 30
kilogramos por metro sobre segundo y
después vimos que una vez que las bolas
chocaron
la bola rebota en un ángulo bueno en una
dirección con un ángulo de 30 grados
y una velocidad de 2 metros por segundo
y usamos esta información para calcular
los componentes x x de esta velocidad
y eso es usamos esto para calcular el
momentum de cada componente y usamos ya
que sabemos que el momento se conserva y
subamos sabemos que la suma de los
momentos en cada elemento o en cada
dimensión es igual a los momentos
iniciales eso lo hacemos para calcular
los momentos en b y una vez que tenemos
esto que tuvimos estos datos calculamos
la velocidad de ve en sus componentes x
y bueno aquí los dibujamos
y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
simplificar esto y si queremos expresar
este vector
como lo hicimos con la velocidad de nada
diciendo un ángulo y una magnitud bueno
vamos a trabajar con un poquito de
trigonometría permítanme calcular esto
bueno limpiar en la pantalla para hacer
este más cálculos no se olviden los
números que calculamos entonces tenemos
que
nuestra componente en x todo esto es de
la bola b era igual a 2.54 metros sobre
segundo y la componente en g
era de
dos metros sobre segundo hacia abajo
y bueno ahora lo que tenemos que hacer
es calcular la hipotenusa y el ángulo
que esto es bueno lo que nos quedamos
para calcular el vídeo pasado
a ellos
qué feos
dibujos esto es igual a una
interrogación
ok bueno entonces para calcular la
hipotenusa pues es fácil ya que tenemos
que aquí hay un ángulo recto y usamos en
el teorema de pitágoras
y para esto tenemos que la hipotenusa va
a ser igual
la raíz cuadrada
de
2.54 al cuadrado más 2 al cuadrado que
es en el cuadrado de este cateto y desde
otro la raíz cuadrada de estos 2
y
haciendo mis cálculos tengo que
6.54 más
4 la raíz cuadrada de todo esto
nos queda
10.45 la raíz cuadrada de 10.45 es
aproximadamente igual a
3.2
metros por segundo entonces la velocidad
aquí la velocidad debe
será igual a 3.2
y bueno ya que queremos calcular el
ángulo y ya conocemos todos los lados
pues podemos realmente usar cualquier
razón trigonométricas vamos a usar una
en la que nos sintamos cómodas entonces
no se vamos a usar el seno
tenemos que el seno del ángulo teta
debe ser igual al cateto opuesto entre
la hipotenusa
y el cateto opuesto es igual a 2 metros
sobre segundo y entre la hipotenusa que
es 3.2 metros sobre 08
entonces el seno de teta debe ser igual
a
0.625
quizás ustedes no estén familiarizados
con el seno inverso o arco seno aún
porque me parece que aún no tenemos
vídeos que expliquen estas funciones
pero lo que tenemos que hacer aquí es la
función inversa al seno
el ángulo theta va a ser igual al arco
seno de 0.625
es decir cuál es el ángulo cuyo seno es
igual a cero punto 625 a esto se refiere
el arco seno y podemos usar google para
hacer este cálculo y debo decirles que
para mí es la primera vez que uso esta
calculadora que tiene google y bueno me
enteré de ella justamente hacer la
traducción de este vídeo entonces
tenemos que queremos calcular el arco
seno
arcos senos
d
0.625
y bueno lo más probable que el resultado
que nos den o los de
radiant es lo que haremos en grados
entonces para convertir de radiales a
grados vamos a multiplicar este
resultado por
/ pin como pueden ver aquí yo ya hice
este cálculo antes pero bueno se los
muestro aquí en él
voy a escribiéndolo directamente
hago esto
y el resultado que me muestra es este
este en ángulo en grados es igual a 38
puntos 68
que es igual entonces
no notemos igual aproximadamente
aquí en algo desconcentrado a ustedes
disculpen
recordemos entonces que es
38.7 aproximadamente
38 punto 7 grados este valor este ángulo
38.7
y bueno pues ya que tenemos todos los
cálculos
espero que se haya comprendido esto
básicamente
bueno tiene esto algún sentido de manera
intuitiva
y si recordamos que nuestra pelota ve
esto era lo que calculamos de nuestra
pelota bien de 5 kilos
esto se movía hacia acá como resultado
de que la pelota
de 10 kilos
lo golpeaba y rebotaba
entonces recordamos aunque ya borre los
datos anteriores la vela la pelota o la
bola tiene una masa de 10 kilogramos la
masa la pelota ve una masa de 5 el
componente en yen de la velocidad de a
era de un metro
por segundo al cuadrado el componente d
era hacia acá era de un metro sobre
segundo y la bebé
es de dos metros por segundo hacia abajo
tiene sentido esto pues claro que sí
porque en su momento un combinado tenía
que ser igual a cero pues no hay un
momento no tenemos momento inicial en
qué y para qué se ocurrieran la
velocidad del bebé tendría que haber
sido el doble d porque ven tiene la
mitad de la masa que a lo mismo pica con
la velocidad general debe esta velocidad
tendría que ser más rápida que la dea
que a la edad era de dos metros por
segundo
así que intuitivamente esto tiene
sentido nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo